Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P..
One of our viewers researched
the origins of the coronavirus
and he figured it out. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, I've been doing my own
research and investigating the origins of
the coronavirus. Yes, I've been through
many forums. I've been on Grabau, I've been on
parler, I've been on Facebook, and I've finally
gotten to the bottom of it. It was antifa,
Speaker 1: exactly, yeah, no, and the you
should see when people say they're doing research,
you should see the things they're doing and what
they're looking at often research. As my aunt
posted a conspiracy article to Facebook and I
read through all the comments and nobody made any
good counterpoints, that counts as research in
some circles. We've got a great bonus show for you
today. Los Angeles is moving towards banning the
unvaccinated from most businesses. We will talk
about the Biden administration again, trying to
end Trump's remain in Mexico policy and obesity
rates way up during the pandemic. We'll explain
the why and the how. Some of it obvious, some less
obvious. Get instant access to today's Bonas show.
Sign up and join Pakman dot com.
Unidentified: I'll see you there.